Vladimir zielinski visited three NATO
countries Friday the Czech Republic
Slovakia and turkey a quick diplomatic
tour ahead of next week's NATO Summit to
push for Sweden's accession and
eventually the same for Ukraine
zielinski made further calls for more
long-range missiles on a day when NATO's
most powerful member announced a new
donation of arms to Ukraine including
controversial cluster Munitions we
recognize that cluster munition's
creative risk of Civilian harm from
unexploited ordinance this is why we've
the defer deferred the decision for as
long as we could cluster Munitions are
bombs that scatter smaller explosives
across a large area like landmines some
can remain unexploded later injuring
civilians the White House says the
unexploded ordinance figure could be as
high as 2.5 percent and suggested that
these are not its first choice voice of
artillery shipments we need to build a
bridge from where we are today to when
we have enough monthly production of
unitary rounds 111 countries including
Canada and most NATO members prohibit
the use production and export of cluster
Munitions those Nations do not include
the U.S Russia or Ukraine Human Rights
Watch says its investigations show both
Russia and Ukraine have used cluster
Munitions in the war causing civilian
injuries and deaths we're not commenting
on any of the other weapons except for
plastic Munitions because they
that is under international law NATO
Chief yens stoltenberg was Norwegian
prime minister in 2008 when his country
hosted the signing of the convention on
cluster Munitions the difference is that
Russia is using customization to attack
to invade Ukraine
a Ukraine is using close termination to
protect itself critics of cluster bombs
say it matters little who fires them if
they later injure or kill a civilian
Redmond Shannon Global News London